[Music]
hello welcome back to chess openings
explained
the current conditions here in st louis
we're gonna have to uh pre-record this
lecture
but hopefully you guys will still enjoy
it
uh the last time we looked at the
trigorin we looked at early captures on
d5
and now we're going to look at some
other options so
here this is just
a little reminder of what we covered
d4 d5 c4 knight c6 this is the trigorin
defense
and after this move we covered what
happens if white takes with the pawn
but this week we are actually going to
be looking at what happens if white ends
up playing knight f3 in this position
and also what happens if they play
knight c3 in this position
so we'll start with knight to f3 i also
want to mention that white also has this
move e3 and this is playable but it's
not too ambitious and the problem with
this is that after move two black
already has a lead in development and
that means that any inaccuracy white
makes can be punished more severely
because they have that extra piece in
the game so i'm not a big fan of e3
but i do want to mention it is playable
now we have knight f3 here and the main
move by black is bishop to g4
after bishop to g4 white can continue
with knight to c3 and i think they
should
the other options they have is i guess
the other main option is queen a4 which
is a sideline black should be aware of
we'll touch on this in just a second
but there's also takes right away and
the problem with capturing early is
going to be the same problem we had in
the capture on move three
is that white gets the bishop pair but
black is usually ahead in peace activity
and
it's uh the positions are not the most
familiar for white
so after takes then bishop takes and
then g takes
and the argument for white's wrecked
pawn structure here
with all these doubled pawns is that
they have the bishop pair
but after takes e3 and e5 this can lead
to some complications
that white doesn't necessarily need to
get into
but go check out part one if you want to
see some more of this imbalance
instead if you're wanting to avoid the
main line
after knight c3
or rather not after knight c3 is just
right away queen a4
and this sideline
black should take on f3 focusing on
quick development and intending to
follow up with a quick bishop to b4
check
trying to get white to block with the
knight and then trade off that bishop
for that knight as well
so this has some interesting ideas after
g takes e6 knight c3 bishop b4
and then we get the the trade on c3
eventually
and again
uh a bit of a messy pawn structure for
white but you do have the bishop pair
and black can continue with uh pretty
natural moves such as 97 after rook b1
hitting the pawn rook b8
and then h4 grabbing space
uh and from here i suggest looking at
the game melaniac versus marisovich in
1994.
but the main move here is uh knight c3
my recommendation and after knight c3
black has two options
um they can capture on f3 and if they do
so
here you can still take with the g pawn
but the line i looked at was e takes f3
and after a black goes e6 you can trade
on d5 here
and then bishop to b5 and white does
have a pretty nice edge here queen b3 is
a nice move to follow castle king side
and the bishop is probably going to go
to f4
if black doesn't take on f3 and instead
they play the main move e6
white has two questions
where should this bishop on c1 develop
to should it go to f4 or should it go to
g5
and should you trade on d5 and if so
should you trade before you develop the
bishop or should you trade after you
develop the bishop
so we will look at all of these
different options here
and we will start with looking at
actually a move a viewer asked about um
pawn to c5 shutting down the queen side
here
and i don't recommend this
black can just trade on f3 and after you
recapture a6 and i don't see how c5 has
benefited to your position you can go
bishop e3 reinforcing d4 bishop e7
bishop to d3 and after knight f6
castle's castles i don't think black has
any problems here um maybe knight d7 and
b6 to chip away at this c5 pawn maybe
even b6 right away but i don't think
white
has done anything to hurt black's
position here
um but back to the two main questions do
you go bishop g5 or bishop f4 so we'll
look at bishop g5
and at the bishop g5 bishop e7
and you can capture on d5 first
uh if they end up capturing on g5 you
can capture on c6 and
material will work itself out after
bishop f3 gf3
takes on c6 black does have these double
isolated pawns
and white does have queen a4 coming up
hitting this weak c6 pawn
so black does better just to take back
right away and
here after takes on e7 knight takes e7
after e3
this leads to some positions that can be
similar to the queen's gambit accepted
um where white just has these two
knights outs and will have some rather
easy development so bishop g5 definitely
playable
the other option here is going bishop f4
after bishop f4 there's two moves i want
to talk about first the mistake
bishop to b4
this move can be met with knight to e5
getting the knight off of f3 where it
can be captured so you're eliminating
the risk of doubling your pawns
and then after knight captures and
bishop captures
if black decides to capture on c3 and we
take back
uh they can hit our our bishop we just
retreat and after 97
this is starting to
be a little reminiscent of nimzo indian
after queen b3 b6 and f3 this is really
starting to look like an f3 nimzo here
after e4
and i think that this is going to be
completely fine for white
the the pawns on the light squares are
doing a good job balancing out this
light square bishop and this knight
really doesn't have any influence over
our position as a whole so our dark
squared bishop i think is better
and this should be a fairly
comfortable position for white
black's main option is to capture on f3
g takes f3 bishop to b4 and now e3 and i
want to clarify this is the entire point
of capturing what the g pawn is so you
can go e3 and build a solid pawn chain
you
excuse me you don't want to capture with
the e pawn and then have a weak d4 pawn
but okay e3 knight e7
a3 takes takes and castles
and here white has the bishop pair with
this awkward pawn structure that we
should be pretty familiar with now
but this structure is not quite as open
as some of the other positions here
and after castles
bishop to g3 this is avoiding knight g6
coming with tempo on the bishop
and it's also a bit of a waiting move to
see what black is going to do
but from here you might be looking at
capturing on d5 like normal queen b3 is
always an option rook b1 to pressure the
pawn over here
you know bishop d3
all these natural moves
white does kind of have the luxury of
waiting to see what black does
so that's what you get with bishop f4
but my recommendation here is actually
to capture first
and the point is that if black captures
back right away now you have bishop f4
and also over time this system is kind
of emerged as
the main line um
you also have bishop g5 here but because
of the amount of content and our time
restraints i'm not going to cover bishop
g5 in this position because i believe
bishop f4 is better
and black's best move to meet bishop f4
is bishop d6 black needs to develop keep
up in pace with white
and one of the ways he can do that is by
challenging this undefended piece right
away
there's also knight f6
which is a little dubious but after e3
bishop b4
blacks had had worse positions here
um
and while there aren't really any
concrete reasons why this is worse an
example line goes as follows where after
these queens develop in white castles
capture on c3 capture on c3 g5 hitting
the bishop the bishop goes back and
castles long
um white does have a bit more flexible
of a pawn structure here as you can see
these pawns are kind of scattered
um not really working together and the
pieces aren't well coordinated no real
clear targets uh whereas with white you
just bring the rooks over to b1
um i think either rook but i suggest the
a rook
and from here
uh i recommend looking at the game bars
versus guizar from what is it
2011. this is a correspondence game
between two twenty one hundreds
or sorry a twenty one hundred and twenty
three hundred
uh that ended in a draw
so
let's see here
instead of knight f6 black should just
go bishop d6 try and trade off the
bishops
and here white should just drop the
bishop back there's no need to take and
let the queen take back and now black is
ready to long castle you can just drop
back to g3 and black needs to spend
another move to try and get his king to
safety
so now a couple more options you can try
knight f6 here after e3 castles bishop
h4
this is avoiding them taking and
doubling our pawns which honestly that's
not even a real problem it would open
your brook up
but this does introduce a rather
annoying pin
and now white is putting pressure
on black's center
so knight f6 a little dubious because of
this bishop h4 idea that you don't see
in many other lines
and now you also have bishop takes f3
here which is always an idea black has
just trade the bishop off for the knight
white always captures with the g pawn
now knight ge7
and now e3
and this is a position that can be
reached if black captures on f3 before
bishop d6 but with this move order white
doesn't have the option of queen to d2
at any point
and trading on f3 also isn't mandatory
and black does have some positions that
are more ambitious
such as knight g to e7 before trading
after knight g to e7 you get e3 and now
if white or sorry if black captures f3
white can recapture with the queen and
this is fine
but black and castle bishop e2 breaking
the pin
now a6
castles king side
now we get bishop g3 because white has
committed to the king side now if white
captures with the h pawn the rook is not
opening up on the h file here
so you're not introducing any risk to
black's king's side and now queen d6 and
i think this position
uh is very
i don't know balance is the right word
um but equal both sides definitely have
chances here
um and really only black has had good
results from this position according to
my database although engines do give
white a plus
um this is a very nice position for both
sides black has a lot of attacking
chances but if white can survive then
the space and uh
i guess yeah really the space and more
flexibility to develop the pieces is
going to prevail
all right in addition to
um
this knight f3 line there is also three
knight c3
and i really think this is the absolute
best try for white
against the trigorin there is d4 d5
c4
knight to c6
and now again instead of capturing
instead of playing knight to f3
you go knight to c3
and here there's a little bit more
flexibility part of it is that white
does retain f3 so you can kick a bishop
if it ever comes to g4 really there's no
reason for black to put the bishop on g4
if the knight is not on f3 yet
and there's a couple problems here black
can face if they continue with normal
looking moves
for example e6
after e6 black is already going to
suffer
long-term problems with the lack of
development of the bishop on c8 you are
trapping it inside your pawn chain
and the knight on c6 really doesn't have
much influence other than pressure on d4
so natural moves are good enough for
white in this position you can simply
play e3 and develop your pieces like
normal and because this knight's
blocking the c pawn it's going to be
very awkward for black to find an
advantage
there's also e5 instead of e6 and
typically black suffers in this line
after c takes and after knight takes d4
e3 hitting the knight right away so the
knight has to go to f5 there's no other
safe square
you have knight f3 putting pressure on
e5 bishop d6 defending
and now bishop to b5 check this induces
bishop d7 blocking and a trade
and after e4 knight f e7 we see that
blacks knights are not the happiest
pieces on the board there's no clear
breakthroughs for black and it's not
entirely clear what side they should be
castling on if they try castling on the
queen side well we already have a bunch
of space on the queen side we'll be
ready to bring our pieces in with queen
b3 and bishop to e3
pointing directly at the king and if
black's going to try and castle king
side then after knight f6 and castle's
king's side there's going to be a bit of
congestion over here for black
so e5
not the best move in my opinion
now the other option black has is knight
f6 which is playable
uh kind of reminiscent of a two nights
tango
uh but there are a couple problems with
the natural play
um so here it just takes on d5 knight d5
knight f3
and some of the natural moves here like
developing this light square bishop can
lead to some problems for example bishop
to f5 actually runs into queen b3 and
how exactly are you going to be saving
your pawn and your knight
well if you try knight b6 well here d5
is going to come in and after a knight
b8 white just has all the space in the
world and e4 can actually be played
right away hitting the bishop bishop has
to go back black has made no progress in
developing their pieces so
uh bishop f5 is a problem because of
queen b3 the other try black has is e6
saying hey if you take my pawn it's
poison
and here it actually is because of
knight d to b4
and you're kind of trapping the queen
here there's no safe space on a6 and
they're also threatening knight to c2 so
this is actually a a big mistake by
white if they take this pawn
but instead the the very natural pawn to
e4
just forking the pieces and if black
takes the knight
you take the bishop and this is the
point that um this knight is under
attack you've made no concessions to
your center the knight goes back to d5
and now you can either take on e6 or
continue development with bishop d2 but
white enjoys a very comfortable position
here with lots of space and black is
awkward awkwardly
not awkwardly placed but they're really
not doing anything for his position here
again other than pressuring d4
so there can be problems now what is
black's best response
well
white has taken this move knight c3 that
doesn't protect c4 black can just take
this pawn
now white will normally go d5
there's also knight f3
and white will normally play this line
if um
well actually i should go through the
line uh but we have knight f6 e4
bishop g4 bishop e3 just defending
everything
e6 bishop takes c4 and this is really
reminding me of a queen's gambit
accepted here really
after bishop b4 queen c2 castles rook d1
um
this is a really safe choice for white
uh
and should be manageable for black but
this is pretty much what it's going to
turn into if
you play
knight f3 here
instead just go d5 hit the knight the
knight really doesn't have many great
moves the only one that really lets it
develop further is e5
and now you have f4
by white so this can be why some people
don't want to play this line because f4
is definitely
not a
go-to move it's not your first instinct
it seems like something you know a pure
beginner would play saying oh i'm just
attacking your knight and i hope you're
gonna leave it i can take it
but now we have knight d7
and we have some very um
interesting moves we have more moves
like this that don't necessarily make a
hundred percent of sense the first you
look at them and are kind of
computer-esque
um
but every night retreat pretty much
leaves uh leads to problems so knight g4
runs into e4 now you're starting to look
at what looks like a four pawns attack
in the
alkyne
uh and after e5 knight f3 you're not
running into any problems with black
takes it actually helps white's
development
you have bishop c5
h3 hitting the knight knight e3
this is the point of bishop c5
but you just trade the bishop and take
the pawn
and after knight e7 bishop takes c4
white is doing just fine all the space
in the world and they're up a pawn
so no problems
if the knight goes to g6 again e4 just
stake that claim in the center now black
normally challenges with e6 you can
actually trade and then this end game is
actually very good for white um
mainly because of um not not an extra
pawn the pawns are equal here but this
big development with the bishop on c4
the knight on c3 this bishop's going to
e3 soon knight f3
very very easy natural development for
white don't have to think too hard with
a space advantage
so after f4 the knight will normally
retreat to d7
where yet again white plays e4 grabs
this space in the center
and we're met with knight b6 just
getting out of the way of the bishop so
the bishop can develop
kind of securing our pawn on c4 here
and white's play is going to be very
direct they play a4 looking to play a5
that way they can take on c4 and the
only way for black to stop this is to
play a5 themselves
and this comes with a positional
drawback
this is a very nice looking outpost for
our knight in the future
if this c pawn ever pushes
but white does need to focus on the rest
of their development they can't focus on
having one beautiful knight and no other
pieces to help it out so that's why we
see bishop e3 here
and after e6 looking to develop further
we see this take on b6
take on b6 and this secures this outpost
for our knight
bishop c4 we regain our pawn
and bishop to b4 so pinning the knight
so unfortunately we won't be able to go
right away
we have bishop b5 check
and king f8 if black tries to block with
the bishop this can run into some
problems after pawn takes because now
this bishop is pinned it can no longer
capture
and the only way to maintain material
equality is to recapture with your
f-pawn
and now queen h5 and this is definitely
looking
pretty scary
pretty scary for black
um
so blocking with the bishop isn't good
you just go king f8
now you take on e6
bishop takes
and f5 hitting the bishop so you see
black's development really all those
pieces are
being awkwardly pushed around by white's
pawns here
i guess the only unnatural thing is how
far these pawns have moved and the king
is not castled but you'll notice black's
developments is just so uncoordinated
with very little targets for white that
there's no problems
takes on d1 rook takes and bishop to b3
hitting the rook
you can also ask yourself what happens
if black ever takes this knight but
after this pawn recaptures uh this is
going to turn into a very strong
uh structure for white because now you
have these two pawns stopping blacks
three there's no way for them to make
progress and white can focus on pushing
down the board here
so no problems here
bishop b3 uh rook d2
and g6
after g6 white just finishes his
development with knight g to e2
and then after g takes f5
knight d4
forking the pawn and the bishop
and now with bishop e6 you can retake
with the pawn you will get your pawn
back and bishop d5
and white still has a very healthy
advantage here you can even take the
bishop they take your rook you take
and after rook d8 you will lose a knight
but there is bishop c4 protecting
and knight to e7 is going to finish
black's development here and the only
way white is better is if they trade
rick takes d4
king c3 to protect the bishop
uh rook c4 king c4 king e7 and now you
have this rook end game which this is
not an endings class this is an openings
class i'm going to leave this one here
but i believe this is probably white's
best try in the trigorin and if i had to
choose a side in this end game it's
going to be white black really doesn't
have any progress to be made on the
queen side here and it's a 3 on 2 on the
other side i find it very hard for black
to generate the chances on the king side
of the board
but there it is there is the rest of the
trigoran defense i hope you guys enjoyed
it um i know this is shorter if there
are any questions about move orders
please drop them down in the comments
section below i'm going to do my best to
make sure i go through them give you
guys the answers you want but there it
is i'll see you next time